so Neil I'm looking on the internet this
is something that's about that's going
viral ant-man will kill thanos by going
into his butt and then expand it so that
he explodes from the inside out back to
the normal size right he could be a
giant now so he can expand it okay first
Wow first that's nasty because if a nose
is as powerful and as evil as he is
right he's gonna have powerful evil poop
okay so I would not want to find myself
in that environment right but I wouldn't
think second why not put something else
in there that expands why does it have
to be your own self I bet you Dino says
quantum but armor that would prevent
that from happening yeah just say I'm
just saying quantum quantum but
protector but panels III I don't know
I'm just saying if you just want to go
in and expand and kill him okay you
don't have to be the person to do that
and then some other thing in there do it
by the way you know he does very very
good
[Laughter]
you